hey at 6 42 if you have ever wondered
how a movie gets made here in las vegas
wonder no more my friends it all starts
with the nevada film office
and eric price now if you see the name
it looks like priest but it's eric price
he is joining us live to talk about the
calls he gets from
hollywood excuse me mr fancy fans
how you doing eric i'm doing fantastic
it's always great to see you
oh likewise my friend thank you so much
so okay eric we had the pandemic
everything shut down prior to that
i mean we had born being shot here so
many other movies being shot here
things have changed since your office
opened
40 years ago most people don't even know
that that you've been here for 40 years
40 years when you say it like that you
wonder where it went
yeah so so so many things have changed
but so much stays the same you know 40
years ago
the office was created because people
want to create content around
nevada s 40 years later that is still
true
it is actually more true than ever
people are creating more content than
ever in human history
and we need to be in that content and we
need to share las vegas and our brand
with the world
yeah absolutely now you and i both know
i think everybody around the world knows
this
las vegas is a character in a movie all
by itself it's really a powerful brand
so
how does this benefit your office when
it comes to attracting those movie
production companies
las vegas is a powerful brand and you
like anyone know that that the brand is
important when you are in business
and so what the nevada film office does
is it builds the brand
how does any how does a brand get built
it gets built through awareness
and an attention to the brand and what
we do through the creation of content
is is we bring awareness and attention
to the brand
if people don't know about your product
it could be the best product
so people need to know about it and we
do that through
exposure and film television music
videos commercials projects
that's how people know about the brand
is through the cons consumption of
content
yeah now how has las vegas benefited we
were just showing uh the shooting of
jason bourne here which was so exciting
i remember it well how do we benefit
economically from
working with the film industry because i
know that it's very important to employ
people who live here
when you're doing that kind of business
here
very much so and you know what's
interesting about the film television
content
creation media industry is that it's so
much behind the scenes people don't see
it i mean everyone is home consuming
content
netflix is doing 20 billion of content
hbo apple hulu everyone's doing content
but you don't see it get made because it
gets made behind the scenes
but it employs a huge number of nevadans
it enlists a huge number of local small
businesses and vendors that support this
industry
but it all happens behind the scenes so
you don't see it
as in your face as you do but when you
turn on that television or when you go
to the movies
you definitely look at the credits and
you see all the people it takes to make
this content it's fantastic
and i absolutely love that i'm all about
community as you know eric it's like
if you're coming here making money the
people who live here need to make some
of that money too
so tell us about the future of the film
industry shooting here in las vegas
uh through and throughout our state any
exciting projects coming up
the future is bright i mean as we look
at the world we see
more people consuming content than ever
in human history
and we need we see more content being
created las vegas and nevada
is going to double down on that and
wants to double down on that so that get
content that's created here it employs
nevadans
and the future of that is really in
building the necessary infrastructure
that it's going to take to film all this
stuff it's got to be made somewhere
yeah and we need the infrastructure to
do it as far as exciting
as far as exciting things coming up we
got some great things that have already
been filmed and or
are filming things like crime scene
investigators las vegas one of the shows
that launched nice
one of the most popular franchises in
all of the 20th century
yeah 20 you know it uh it's going to be
coming back and it's going to be filming
csi in las vegas
okay fantastic and then um i believe
it's may 21st on netflix the movie army
of the dead is going to premiere
heavily features las vegas huge
production for netflix being directed
by zack snyder no that's going to be a
big a big summer move
okay all right eric i'm out of time you
know i can talk to you all day long
because
you mentioned a scary movie and i'm all
in but hey for students who are thinking
about a future in film
is your office open and available how
would they get in touch with you because
again we're such a big brand i know a
lot of kids here
probably want to get involved yeah you
know the programs at unlv
and college of southern nevada there's
so many fantastic
film audio visual programs
i would highly encourage students to
check out the programs there
and then to reach out to our office and
our resources coordinator at the
office to net toll who works closely
with a lot of students okay
a lot of opportunities coming up so it's
it's it's pretty exciting
i was always visit the website at
nevadafilm.com
all right and it's always exciting
talking to you my friend thank you so
much it's good to see you again
great to see you thank you so much all
right take care and hey folks don't
forget catch my moj show facebook live
tonight 7 p.m of course we're going to
replay our interview with eric give you
a little more information
as well but hey this was so much fun